في العشرين من يوليو عام
1969 هبطت اول مركبه فضائيه على سطح القمر
في حدث تاريخي شكل انجازا كبيرا ليس فقط
في تاريخ الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بل
وفي تاريخ العالم باسره ولمع معها اسم
رائدي الفضاء نيلارمسترونج
لكن احدا لم يذكر مايكل كولينز الذي كان
جزءا من هذا الانجاز فما قصته
ولد مايكل كولينز في ايطاليا عام
1930 لاب عسكري وانتقلت عائلته الى واشنطن
ابان الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهناك امضى
طفولته قبل ان ينتقل لنيويورك حيث حصل على
درجه البكالوريوس من اكاديميه ويست بوينت
العسكريه وهو مؤهله للالتحاق بالقوات
الجويه كطيار مقاتل خلال فتره خدمته قطع
كولين اكثر من اربعه الاف ومئتين ساعه
طيران قبل ان تختاره وكاله ناسا في عام
1963 ليكون من ضمن المجموعه الثالثه لرواد
الفضاء الخاصه بها قام كولينز برحله
الفضاء الاولى في الثامنه عشر من يوليو
عام
1966 وكانت مهمه الجوزاء حيث قام كولينز
بالسير في الفضاء اما مهمته الثانيه فكانت
مهمه ابولو 11 الشهيره خلال الفتره من الح
حتى العشرين من يوليو عام
1969 حيث قاد مهمه اول هبوط على سطح القمر
في التاريخ كان كولينز الجندي المجهول
الذي رافق كلا من نيل ارمسترونج حيث بقي
كولنس في قمره القياده بينما كان شركاؤه
يسيرون على سطح القمر وهو ما تطلب منه
الدوران حول القمر حتى يوم الحادي
والعشرين من يوليو فامضى نحو 28 ساعه في
عزله عن العالم بانتظار عوده رفيقيه
ارمسترونج والدرين وعادوا معا الى الارض
هبطت المركبه في المحيط الهادئ في الرابع
والعشرين من يوليو وحصل كل من كولينز
وارمسترونج والدرين على وسام الحريه
الرئاسي من قبل ريتشارد نيكسون بقي كولينز
يعمل في وكاله ناسا حتى يناير عام 1970
سجل خلالها 266 ساعه في الفضاء ثم اصبح
مساعدا لوزير الخارجيه للشؤون العامه في
عام
1991 انضم الى مؤسسه سميث سونيان كمدير
للمتحف الوطني للطيران والفضاء ثم اصبح
نائب رئيس شركه ال تي في للفضاء والدفاع
لمده خمس سنوات ثم بدا عمله الخاص كمستشار
مستقل يكتب ويحاضر في علوم الفضاء بعيدا
عن الاضواء كتب كولينز عده كتب حمل النار
عام
1974 الطيران الى القمر واماكن غريبه اخرى
عام 19
الاقلاع قصه مغامره امريكا في الفضاء عام
1988 مهمه الى المريخ عام
1990 قبل وفاته بمرض السرطان 28 من ابريل
عام 2021
منح كولينز درجات فخريه من ست جامعات ونال
ايضا اوسمه وجوائز كثيره لكن شيئا لم
يعوضه عن تلك اللحظات التي تذكر فيها مهمه
ابولو 11
وينسى اسمه